I do these little promos uhhuh of people
that are in the
book so I'll just do like a minute long
thing yeah for sure take a look at
that I took full responsibility for what
I did and what I've always done
ultimately because I feel that I did it
I was in the stolen car that I was
driving I made the decision to take them
on a chase it was all my fault what
happened to me so I decided I wasn't
going to be angry about it I wasn't
going to cry about it I was wasn't going
to make other people feel pity for me I
was just going to man up I was going to
get through and get on with my life and
that's what I've attempted to do to this
day I like that dude I like that a
lot what do you
think I love it ever since I've done
this you know like people stop me on the
street they recognize me they wish me
well that people you know the kindness
of their heart help me out you know I
mean some people ask me if I need help
and you know I'm not trying to to take
from people like like unnecessarily so
you know sometimes I turn people down
with respect you know but I'm like man
hey just you recognize me as awesome and
like you know like I said dude I have a
big thanks to you because it's because
of you that I've been able to even
attempt to get my life back you know
like this is this has opened up so many
like different avenues for me that I
mean the only you know it's only looking
up but it helps with your selfworth a
little bit absolutely you know being on
the streets dude like I had this
I had this your your your um your uh
what's it called your um your confidence
level goes down you know what I mean you
start looking rough you start not
maintaining yourself and then you know
you see I see the way people look at me
you know sometimes I get Shady looks
sometimes I get like pity looks and some
you know some people recognize it for
what it is that I mean that I'm I'm just
out here struggling and I'm just trying
to find my way like everybody else you
know I'm just
I'm just trying to find my way what
works for me now you know like me and my
baby's mom aren't together anymore but I
still have my son and for me that's
everything I still have to be a full
role model to him you know and I mean I
want to I want to get a job I want but
see the whole thing is I want to try to
find what my like what am I passionate
about what am I you know what keeps me
going I mean I I'm into music I love
making beats and um a friend of mine uh
he uh he started this band and it's
called noise pollution and you know uh
I'm a part of that I want I want to DJ
for him I want to bring it to life you
know because he's an amazing musician
you know and I
mean man you know
like I
just I can't I can't I can't see myself
just wasting away anymore you know I
used to be okay with just getting loaded
and if whatever happened happened but
now I mean I got so much going on I'm
going I'm getting housing you know I I
had got I went to jail and um I had to
do six months so I got bumped out of the
program and I worked hard to get with
Lassa to get me housing and it was
messed up the way it all worked out but
it's for a reason and I got out I got a
cell phone I got it cracking again and I
I'm actually today I talk with the
director and uh I'm going to get back in
housing today so I'm getting off the
street that's great yeah that's great
having the just caring about yourself
having the self worth to to to care
about yourself I think is a huge part of
all this absolutely
it's I can't believe I let myself fall
so far you know what I mean
like I can't wait to see what tomorrow
brings you know what I mean it's nice to
hear you're hopeful yeah I am I'm very
nothing but proud I'm proud to have you
in this book I'm dude I'm I'm very very
flattered that I mean this is amazing
dude like I never thought I mean I read
all the comments I read you know from
people and everything and how positive
they were and look to everybody that did
comment I love every one of you I'm
sorry my my life is just chaos and I
couldn't respond to you guys
individually at that point but I just
want to thank everybody for all the
positive feedback and you guys are a big
big part of you know what what built me
back up up
and you know like oh thank you Mark you
know like this whole thing is giving me
giving me a second chance man to
actually be a man and grow up you know
you're still a young man too yeah you
know maybe maybe go to Homeboy
Industries and maybe maybe work on
getting a couple taken off the face
maybe or you know might not be a bad
idea yeah all right Donnie thank you so
much man yeah man thank
you I look at this [__] like dude like
this is
[__] like literally like a piece of
history now and I'm [__] there bud I
love that [__]
dude like dude I read those comments few
people all over the world dude like
that's amazing to me I never thought me
telling my story would
matter